مطالبه من برلمانيين وجمعيات حقوقيه
بالتخلي عن قرار ارسال طالب اللجوء غير
النظاميين الى رواندا بعد ان اقرت المحكمه
العليا البريطانيه بقانونيه ترحيلهم
تعالى الهتافات المعرضه للحكم والصفا ممثل
الجمعيات الحقوقيه والمعارضه لكي يعربوا
عن ادانتهم للقرار قائلين انه لن يفلح في
وقف حاله الهجره غير النظاميه وزيره
الداخليه الظل من حزب العمال كوبر وصفت
خطه رواندا بغير الاخلاقيه مضيفه انها
بمثابه صرف انتباه عن الاجراء الذي يجب
على الحكومه اتخاذه لتعقب العصابات
الاجراميه واصلاح نظام اللجوء من جانب اخر
قالت منظمه العفو الدوليه في المملكه
المتحده ان خطه رواندا يجب التخلي عنها
وبين شد وجذب اكدت وزيره الداخليه
البريطانيه سويلا بريفمن قانونيه هذا
القرار مستندا الى قرار المحكمه العليا
وقالت بريفر من انها ستركز على تطبيق
سياسه الترحيل في اسرائيل وقت ممكن
الانتقال الى رواندا ليس عقاب
لكنه طريقه مبتكره لمعالجه مشكله الرئيسيه
لتصحيح الاختلاف بين طرق الهجره غير
القانونيه والقانونيه وسيكفل ايضا توفير
الحمايه الدوليه لمنهم في حاجه حقيقيه
اليها في رواندا
وقال المتحدث باسم رئيس الوزراء
البريطانيه
ان رئيس الوزراء رحب بقرار المحكمه العليا
ولم يقدموا المتحدث اطارا زمنيا لمواعيد
انطلاق الرحلات الجويه لكنه اضاف قائلا
نريد ان نمضي باسرعه وقت ممكن كما رحبت
المتحدثه باسم الحكومه روانديه يولاندي
مقوله بهذا القرار وقالت انك جاء لي
مستعده لتوفير الامان طالب اللجوء
والمهاجرين وتقديم الفرصه لبناء حياه
جديده في رواندا واضافت ان هذه خطوه
ايجابيه للمساهمه في حلول خلاقه وطويله
الاجر لازمه الهجره العالميه فهل تنجح
الخطوه البريطانيه في حل ازمه تدفق طالب
اللجوء الى الاراضي البريطانيه